good evening everybody
I remember when I first encountered
Agnes vardas work I was a graduate film
student in the 1990s voraciously
devouring films that reflected how I
lived and how I wanted to express my
life and art I loved directors with
great passion and with great vision the
early guys you know the studio guys the
foreign guys the experimental guys and
the French new-wave
guys then I saw a movie called vagabond
at the ontology Film Archives downtown
it was eye-opening it was a revelation
now I had rarely seen movies made by
women most of us hadn't and here was
Agnes imagining and creating female
protagonists who were their own people
like Citizen Kane vagabond starts with a
death and reconstructs the life behind
it but in contrast to Kane a rich old
mogul and a man the protagonist Mona is
a woman like I had never seen before on
screen she was young she was poor
she was unbathed and she was a drifter
she is not interested in being part of
the establishment and more radically she
is sexual on her own terms
she [ __ ] men
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay
she [ __ ] men I'd see that joke work but
refuses to spend any time shaping
herself into a female object or a
feminine ideal academic Molly Haskell
says she eluded all claims of men and
law in other words she didn't give two
[ __ ] or even one [ __ ] for that matter
and what about what men or society or
anybody thought I know it just it goes
on
I love varda for putting her on screen
without justifying her desires and
without making her a woman who was
trying to break free neither Mona nor
Vardis seemed to be in defiance trying
to be revolutionary they just were
Novartis Frank but still sexy portrayal
of human desire on a screen that had
been dominated by men
galvanized us particularly female and
queer filmmakers to tell our own stories
and pyre inspired by her I pushed to
create characters who similarly did not
give a [ __ ] and lived and loved the way
they wanted so I guess it's thanks to
varda indirectly at least that boys
don't cry received an X rating now I
thought an X rating was great
most of my heroes had gotten X's however
I quickly found out it wasn't our studio
Fox who's over there couldn't well
actually no studio can practically
release a movie with an X the problem
was Brandon goes down on Lana and the
orgasm was too long so I went to the
MPAA and I pointed out how many men have
orgasms in movies in American Pie he
comes twice in a row
and there's something about Mary's
Stiller ejaculates explosively it ends
up in Cameron Diaz's hair
man will orgasming all over the place
and they were taking a long time to do
it so why couldn't we have a long female
orgasm who has ever been hurt by an
orgasm that lasted too long they had no
answer they're still looking Varda is is
to blame
Varda is not only revolutionary and
bringing forth uncompromising characters
and inspiring many of us to do so but
also in creating the cinematic spaces
that allow them to exist her character's
inner quest their consciousness rather
than a typical hero's journey shaped the
form of the film itself over her as she
said to me earlier 62 years making more
than 50 films she's created radically
fierce characters that are still radical
today it's amazing through all this
Agnes has remained true to herself and
to her vision she is a kindred spirit of
anyone who seeks to make films about all
the places love and sexual longing
brings us and by moving between multiple
forms of cinema documentary narrative
experimental long and short she has
pushed the form into wonderful ways
which is why it's taking two of us from
two different branches to present her
this award it's yours
well sadly we don't have a lot of
orgasms and documentaries but a few
years ago on yes Varda was being honored
by the International Documentary
Association and my dear friend Lynn
Lippmann asked me to work with her to
edit a tribute reel and Lynn had been a
friend of and colleague of on yes since
the late sixties when she worked as her
assistant in Hollywood and while we were
editing the tribute reel Linwood our gal
knew with stories about working with on
yes like the time they were running
through the streets of Hollywood Lynn
was schlepping lenses capturing a
demonstration about the Black Panthers
for a documentary that on yes was making
about the Black Panthers here in LA Lynn
said that the reason no one ever
complained about long hours and
unconventional tasks was that onion sir
self worked longer and harder and more
unconventionally than all of us put
together
editing that reel was just a wonderful
crash course in magical filmmaking it
was so powerful the poignancy the humor
the joy and the love every frame of
Anya's work was it was a work of art and
I think that probably stems from the
fact that she began as a still
photographer but the way that she saw
the world and the way she captured it
and gave it to us one documentary that
she made in Cuba
salut Lake Cubano was created from 4,000
black-and-white stills that she shot in
Cuba and I have a producer friend
Alisa Nam yes who describes Agnes as a
revolutionary artist she told me that
her Cuban friends who hung out with on
yes in the 60s on the island said she
was the sexiest smartest person they
knew and basically have the whole island
mesmerised pretty good huh
but one of my favorite documentaries of
all times is the Gleaners and I and I
love how I'm yes described making it she
said filming especially a documentary is
gleaning rummaging scavenging things
with our owners Clark's without hands
myself I am just as much a Gleaner
on yes I thank you for a lifetime of
gleaning
agnus on behalf of the directors branch
and my fellow governor's Steven
Spielberg and Michael Mann and the
documentary branch and Kate's fellow
governors Roger Ross Williams and Rory
Kennedy we congratulate you
[Applause]